[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace andino esta vez
desde bolivia en el programa de hoy les
hablaremos sobre la polarización
política del país también les contaremos
sobre un leve repunte de la economía de
bolivia lo que ha permitido a los
ciudadanos de este país mejorar su
situación económica después de que ésta
se ha hundido durante la pandemia
también les mostraremos los
extravagantes cholet aquellos edificios
que están ubicados en la ciudad de el
alto donde habita la burguesía aymara de
bolivia
la crisis política de bolivia tiene su
origen en el referendo del 21 de febrero
de 2016 cuando evo morales- incumplió el
mandato de no postularse a un cuarto
periodo en 2019 las protestas en su
contra las denuncias de fraude de parte
de la oea y las presiones de las fuerzas
de seguridad le obligaron a renunciar al
cargo
en 2020 el movimiento al socialismo su
partido volvió a ganar las elecciones
esta vez con luís arse como candidato el
nuevo presidente que ya cumplió un año
en el cargo lejos de tener paz para
gobernar enfrenta sistemáticas protestas
de las regiones de los opositores
políticos y de los grupos civiles
contrarios al gobierno que se oponen a
sus leyes a las que califican de
autoritarias y persecutorias
una de las acciones del gobierno es
enjuiciar y mantener en la cárcel a la
ex presidenta transitoria que reemplazó
a evo morales
gianni de años a quien culpa de un golpe
de estado en 2019 también están presos
quienes fueron sus ministros y los ex
altos jefes militares y policiales de la
época los opositores acusan a darse y
sobre todo a morales que sigue teniendo
una posición gravitante en el gobierno
de persecución política el más en cambio
denuncia que la oposición busca la
desestabilización del gobierno para
crear las condiciones de un nuevo golpe
de estado
este gobierno tienen las espaldas y se
lo dijo en su momento un largo camino
que recorrer para ir afianzando la
convivencia democrática muchas de sus
acciones van a permitir que encontremos
un camino común hasta el momento parece
que eso no está marchando de esa manera
por el contrario han optado más bien por
por poner sobre la mesa lo que está
ahorita es el discurso político
nuevamente de polarización a veces hay
que preguntar si es una pregunta válida
que es cambiante con los tiempos si la
polarización realmente está solamente en
el discurso de los y los líderes
políticos o si está también dentro de la
sociedad yo creo que los bolivianos
podemos contestar esa pregunta muy
fácilmente ahora respecto a los
políticos los políticos están felices en
el escenario de policía cep les encanta
quieren vivir ahí y ahí se van a quedar
y ya está creo que eso es indiscutible y
no importa la afiliación la opción
política que te guste eso eso lo vemos
con claridad la política es todavía un
terreno turbulento para luís arse donde
parece irle mejor es en la economía
según datos oficiales al segundo
trimestre de este año el país ha crecido
a 9.4 por ciento aunque organismos
internacionales calculan que el país es
cerrará con 5% de crecimiento este año
analistas económicos consideran sin
embargo que este crecimiento es en
realidad un efecto rebote de la abismal
caída durante la pandemia el economista
y profesor universitario
gonzalo chávez asegura que mientras
bolivia continúe en este modelo
estatista primario y exportador
boliviano podrá llegar a un modelo
sostenible
per nativamente primero tienes que
pensar que el desarrollo tiene que ser
diferente ahora la economía ya no está
en la tierra la economía está en el
cielo está en el cielo del internet todo
el mundo está caminando hacia una
economía digital una economía mucho más
innovadora donde no son los recursos
naturales el valor más importante sino
el capital humano las personas la
educación entonces y no cierto los
desafíos por lo tanto es ya no pensar
solamente el desarrollo como crecimiento
creció 45 6% el desarrollo de manera
integral cuanto menos pobreza al capital
humano calidad de educación calidad de
salud calidad de medio ambiente entonces
si tú quieres cambiar esto y en el mundo
mucha gente lo está haciendo tienes que
pavimentar la salida de manera diferente
no volviendo al modelo primario
exportador que cree que estaba haciendo
maravillas
el gobierno de arse aplicó algunas
medidas de entrada como pagar un bono
contra el hambre de 143 dólares a todos
aquellos que no tuvieran ingresos además
de cobrar un impuesto a la riqueza los
empresarios consideran que lo he hecho
es insuficiente para reactivar
verdaderamente el aparato productivo
porque solo crece el comercio informal
la ciudad del alto es la segunda más
poblada de bolivia y en ella habita la
burguesía aymara del país que es
producto del crecimiento de la economía
informal y que es dueña de unos
impresionantes edificios conocidos
popularmente como chalets un término que
mezcla las palabras solo y chalet los
famosos solé son edificios vistosos que
empezaron reivindicando la cultura
andina pero que ahora están tomando
nuevas formas y así en el alto se pueden
encontrar construcciones en forma de los
superhéroes de los transformers también
con la imagen de ironman oeste que luce
la estatua de la libertad en lo alto más
vistoso a un otro que va tomando la
forma de un enorme barco todo un
simbolismo para un país como bolivia que
no tiene acceso al mar y así llegamos al
final de enlace andino siga nuestra
programación en france 24 y france 24
puntocom